yo have you and uh I feel like um
it's crazy to me that you and Cassie
haven't done like a little like joint EP
or something at this point to all the
goddamn music and touring y'all have
done together have you guys ever talked
about that the crazy thing is on tour
uh shout out to casket because he was on
tour how many records did we do in like
three days
it's like
for a mixtape but then it was like 13
all together
so we we have the music right
doesn't matter it's a matter of when is
it ever going to come out
it I mean it should in the future it's
like touring sober and he's like you
know wakes up does burpees and drinks
coffee and doesn't do it like totally
different vibe on this tour than like
previous tours in terms of debauchery
and just like
definitely like
bro it's definitely like just like how
you said like he gets up and he'll just
like you'll have a con while you're
having a conversation with me just doing
burpees out of nowhere right and then me
I'm like dude uh do we get Miller lights
yet
so you know but it evens out like right
guys can get along perfectly well you
know what I'm saying like it's it's
funny as hell though because we're Paul
Robinson yeah I'm dying passing me to
brew I'm chilling you go ahead and do
the burpees I'm gonna do cush-ups and
wear straight push-ups and burpees
that's the name of the [__] collab EP
there it is
Kush up some burpees I'm not mad at that
uh well look hopefully we get this new
album soon man sooner than later no it's
it'll be out real soon much sooner than
anything do you have a name
the thing is you know the name but I'm
not going to tell you the name
doing everything
you know the name
I don't know the name you really do
that's the crazy thing
oh holy Center nah what
we'll talk about it
was the goth Surfer nah
[Laughter]
I'm looking at the object
which is called doobie self-titled
self-titled would you look at that would
you look at that I told you we got it
the self-titled album finally coming
soon
by the way
what was the [__] song The interlude
on the [__] album from like 2018 or
19 it's like my sh Fe you're so
different I still listen to that [__]
all the time
that beat breakdown in that [__]
that's just hold up
bro I just I'm like back and forth
between that and the club
great clever song
is so good I love that word traps are
clever what happened to clever man we
gotta he's such a great voice he just
dropped another record as far as caught
a red on the carpet super talented kid
man grown man anyway DJ highlights gonna
go put a sweater on he's cold I'm
[__] freezing inside I'm shivering I
don't know if y'all can see me I'm cold
as it is freezing in here
um well new album self-titled coming up
before summer
before summer yeah yeah okay